I think it's great to that you decided
to more so than the paper resume and all
that you decided to get all of your
online stuff in order and sometimes I'll
see people that have a great IMDB page
but they don't have their own website
for themselves yeah they're not on
Twitter or whatever what's your advice
to those people because sometimes you
hear them say well if I get people I
want them to do all that for me but you
can't you in order for people in order
for you to get people who want to work
for you you need to show initiative and
you need to not only show initiative you
need to start building your own base of
work that entices those people to want
to work for you so until you have those
people you're those people you know you
have to do that stuff there's everyone
else is doing it all your competitors
are doing it so if you don't you're only
hurting yourself you know you should be
on Twitter building some sort of
audience for yourself you should have
your own website so when someone
Google's you that's the first thing that
comes up rather than somebody else with
your same name you know they're also
like some break down websites that
casting directors use a lot that you
should be updating those all actors
access and now casting I believe actors
access is well now castings more LA I
heard because I didn't really use that
in New York but those two sites you
should be on and updating yeah you it's
your your publicist until someone wants
to be your publicist
you